Mélina a 24 ans et elle est enceinte de
deux mois vous cherchez un logement
trouver du travail c'est dur dans ce
refuge du quartier hochlaga où elle dort
c'est la misère il y a beaucoup de
personnes aiment qui consomment
je répète des crises au lieu des aux
yeux des aider plus envoyer
admettons à l'hôpital psychiatrique des
choses comme ça et maintenant rue encore
et dans la rue difficile aussi de se
faire une place au début de l'été une
pétition a été lancée pour pousser le
refuge qui ne devait y être que pour un
an à déménager selon les 340 signataires
le lieu écrit trop d'insécurité dans le
quartier et l'organisme Captain Barnabé
qui le gère en fait peu pour limiter les
nuisances selon des résidents ont la
ligne des chaises juste pour refuser
personne la directrice de CAF
saint-barnaby cherche des places pour
relocaliser les résidents mais la
réalité c'est que les refuges débordent
on a beau vouloir accueillir des gens
quand même on a beau vouloir trouver
d'autres endroits mais qu'on appelle
ailleurs voir d'autres partenaires sont
plein aussi c'est ça qui ont fait quoi
après ça sans rouler solution
être de rue au cœur de Ville-Marie vit
le même défi le centre d'injection
supervisé est très achalandée et il
dérange des voisins on avait un
travailleur de milieu qui s'assurait de
tout ça puis qui parlent avec les
commerçants mais dans les dernières
financements qu'on a eu ce poste là a
été coupé c'était assez magique d'avoir
quelqu'un qui était dédié et au
ramassage de soigne et au bon voisinage
la cohabitation avec les voisins risque
d'être problématique selon les
organismes tant qu'il n'y aura pas plus
d'argent pour financer leurs services et
pour offrir des logements sociaux à des
gens comme Mélina je leur demande de
tolérant parce que eux ils ont un chez
eux nous notre chez nous c'est l'Église
c'est nous on veut juste s'en sortir
comme comme les gens normaux
ici Charles Dumoulin Radio-Canada
Montréal